we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p earlier in the
week said i'm no longer going to be
apologizing and explaining things to the
five percent of my audience that needs
things to be explained and and
disclaimed uh here's a caller who says
david i hate to break it to you it's not
five percent of your audience twenty
percent of your audience is is that dumb
i disagree but here's the caller
do you think
that it's only five percent of your
audience who requires your what you
consider to be
over explaining david
number one you're not really over
explaining
uh
not by a long shot you know what's funny
this guy is in that five percent this is
a caller
who has a call after i say things like
i'm not for
aggression and boots on the ground you
know i i give all the disclaimers
this is a guy who is called in
completely ignoring everything i said
whatever his opinion is he's in the
group whether it's the five or twenty
percent number two i think it's way more
than five percent maybe it could be as
high as
20
that's a gut feeling i have based on
life experience
and all other things that need to go
into that mix your education experiences
uh i said life experience yeah um listen
whether it's five or twenty percent this
guy is in that group because i've had to
explain things multiple times because he
calls in all angry
uh attributing the the worst possible
faith interpretation of what i said so
okay anyway it's maybe five percent
maybe ten we'll look into that we have a
great bonus show for you today
unfortunately and this is really
unfortunate as predicted
what's going on in russia ukraine
is giving china some ideas
and taiwan has now raised its alert
level
we're going to talk about that
also justin trudeau has ended his use of
the emergencies act related to the
canadian trucker convoy saying it's no
longer necessary there were people
saying this is the beginning of a
permanent emergencies act there was no
evidence of that and trudeau has already
ended it and lastly
the the international space station
program is ending and we're going to
talk about what comes next
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show i would love for you to sign
up and get instant access
sign up at
joinpacman.com i'll see you then